i want you to kind of give us uh
what a day because i know even right now
your son's a cop in jersey
right and he's been one for a while and
i want i want people to know what is the
difference between being a cop today
after the whole defunding police after
the whole campaign of
you know the way cops are being painted
right now if a
story comes out that favors cops being
bad they'll highlight it all over the
place if a story comes out with the cops
doing the right thing
it may get uh shared in a couple places
but they're not going to share it so
it's only the
bad part that they're shown with cops
right what is the difference between
being a cop
in the 80s 90s versus being a cop
in 2021 2020 i think the biggest
difference is
the the public image of
policing has changed and because of this
radical left-wing movement
um you know what i i think is a a
pretty substantial push for socialism in
the country
you know back in the 80s 90s 70s
police officers male female they were
respected in the community in your
classrooms
your children were taught you know cops
are the good guys
they go out and they do a job that a lot
of people wouldn't do
a lot of people wouldn't have the
courage to do uh they're underpaid
they're understaffed
um and people respected them just like
you respected people in the military
over the last 20 years or so especially
the last
10 over the last 10 years 12 years
that's all changed and there's been this
major push
by the radical left to demonize police
and we have a lot of this going on right
now in especially in major cities and
what's ironic
it's those major cities that have this
push to victimize the thugs and
villainize the cops it's those major
cities
that are run in a manner um
contrary to the way giuliani ran new
york city
and their violent crime their shootings
their their murder rates are through the
roof
because there's no accountability
because they're not enforcing the laws
because they have district attorneys
that are being funded by these radical
left-wing organizations soros
um you know soros funded the guy in
philly the d.a
he funded the the woman in saint louis
there's a bunch of these district
attorneys in cities around the country
that are not prosecuting people to break
the law
and then you have legislators that that
create laws
and governors sign off on them like in
california
you know you could walk into a cvs in
california
and steal 995 dollars worth of
goods and walk out and you cannot be
charged
anything under a thousand dollars can be
charged
wait can you say that one more time say
that one more time so you
you can go in and basically steal up to
999 dollars
worth of material out of uh out of a
store and nobody's gonna charge you with
a crime this is what city
what state this is california in
california
california today tell me that is not the
most pathetic thing you've ever
can go into heard store are you this is
a law in california no it's it's yeah
it's laws
and prosecutors will not prosecute so
what is it anything less than a thousand
anything less than a thousand so that
that's so why doesn't anyone just go
into any store and just say i'm taking
this
pretty much they are in in a bunch of
stores are closing down
but here's here's the problems what you
have now
is a three-prong problem you have
legislators and governors that are
enacting legislation
that handcuff the cops that
you know bail reform these bail reform
laws
you can't hold anybody that you're
locking up anymore
um that's number one number two the
prosecutors
they're targeting cops more than than
they're targeting bad guys
and uh and i think the third thing
is handcuffing the cops in general where
you have
like for example in new york city you
have
the mayor of new york city who's
basically during the riots last summer
told the cops take a light touch de
blasio de blasio
take a light touch on crime so you have
all that going on and then you got this
this push by black lives matter and
antifa
primarily black lives matter and groups
like that
where they're creating this vision that
there's systemic racism in policing
in that cops primarily target
blacks and and brown people um
you know to go out and shoot them right
uh you know without cause you know uh
and i sent uh actually said something to
sam i don't know if you guys got it
uh you got you got that uh
yeah they're gonna bring up something i
want to show you because
these are real numbers okay real numbers
um that are going on right now these are
numbers i'm going to show you for
2020. okay and in doing that
you know if you listen to the mainstream
media if you listen to what's being
reported
you'll you'll hear people say that cops
you know they shoot unarmed blacks far
more than they
shoot unarmed whites okay
so i'm going to show you something
at a close to 50 million police suspect
interactions
50 million 50 million
there's 10 million arrests in the
country
last year 2020 2020 20
of interactions 10 million arrests
they fatally shot police fatally shot at
a 10 million arrest
they shot 1021 people okay right
out of that number fatally shot 983 were
male
38 female 457
were white 243 were black
170 latino 151 other
but here's the interesting number
especially given what you hear
in the media unarmed suspects
unarmed 24 white 18 black
eight hispanic five other
the percentage the status coming from
where this is coming from
so the the arrest numbers are coming
from the fbi okay
those fatally shot numbers they're
coming from the washington post which
keeps a major
washington post that's right they keep a
major database on
fatality shootings dating back to 2015.
okay washington post is not friends of
the cops
no they're not they're on the left okay
those are the numbers
the chances of you being shot as a black
male today
unarmed based on last year's numbers is
0.00018
really that's systemic
that's systemic racism come on in
and here's the bottom line cops don't go
to communities
based on race they go to communities
based on crime
what they do is they they they take a
map of a city
they put a map of a city on a computer
like this
they pin map where that crime is
happening
the dispatching of the police the police
resources
the funding everything is focused on
where the crime is
there's nothing on there that says what
color you are in the community
there's nothing on there that says what
religion you are
where you come from whether you're a
citizen or not
nothing it's strictly based on crime so
when you look at the
when you look at that big crime map this
is where the crime is
that's where the cops are going and
unfortunately you have cities today
like atlanta baltimore minneapolis
chicago new york city
they're all every single one of those
cities are run by a democrat
they're run by a democrat and every
single one of them are facing the same
issues
the highest violent crime highest murder
rates
higher shooting rates and
there's between the laws
between the prosecutors and handcuffing
the cops
those numbers are going to continue so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye